and just behind me on the big screen
here there's a great big picture of um
skye brown um you're luckier than that
aren't you
yep we've got the young lady here
herself with the big smile as his
customer is we saw so much yesterday
skye brown smile is one of the
highlights of these games hi skye how
are you doing hi i'm doing very good
you're yawning a little bit you're a bit
tired aren't you a little bit yeah i
watched the finals men's finals today
and it was insane and what was your day
like yesterday because you had ups and
downs you fell and then you had that
final run didn't you to try and nail a
big performance yeah
those two runs were
insane and i usually like pretty
consistent usually but
that were a little bit heavy but
honestly following those two times
honestly made it feel even better so i'm
happy could have done a little safer run
but all i wanted was to make that trick
and yeah and show us your bronze medal
hold it up for us
an olympic medal winner age 13.
so it's insane
you've said that word a lot haven't you
last 24 hours insane probably like a
hundred thousand times and we were in
there watching you yesterday kind of so
hot and you it was just like you were
hanging out with your friends yeah
that's what it's like yeah honestly
it
it feels like home when all your friends
are there and
we all push each other and we just have
lots of fun and you're hugging each
other you're so pleased when someone
pulls off a really good stunt and so
supportive when someone falls
yeah
yeah we're all happy when someone makes
a trick and we all bumps when someone
falls as well yeah now let's talk about
why you're representing team gb because
you could have represented japan where
you were born here
you live in california some of the time
tell us about why you decided to go for
great britain well we weren't going to
do the olympics because
well
i wanted to of course but my parents
they were like there's too much special
sky you know
don't do it but team gb was like
try it out you know you can quit anytime
you want to just try if you like it yeah
keep going and see what happens and your
dad's
the reason why it was great britain
because he was born in hastings down on
the south coast of england yeah i think
so i think that's where he was born yeah
yeah i'm half british half japanese and
one of the
new music tracks that you skated to
yesterday was park life by blur which
kind of came out way before you were
born who chose that music
i don't know i think it just came on or
i don't really know i didn't even really
hear it but i was just skating and
skating and hanging with my friends yeah
and i know that you kind of obviously
live in california most the time but you
have visited london fairly recently and
you do quite a good british accent don't
you sky could you give us a bit uh
i can't do it right now but yeah i do we
do love london we go there quite a bit
and
it's it's beautiful i love london i love
i love the accents and the food mangas
and mash um
i love it all right you're a bang is a
mash girl
that's good to hear and tell me kind of
you're a great surfer as well we know
that
you've been talking about maybe in paris
three years time doing skateboarding and
surfing is that possible
i mean
it definitely is possible but i do know
it's going to be
hard it's going to be very hard but
i love surfing i love skating and
honestly surfing's skating my friends
will be really fun and going to paris as
would be awesome it's like one of my
favorite countries and i mean and in
fiji i mean it'll be awesome because the
surfing's down in french polynesia isn't
it the other other side of the world but
just tell us guys there's lots of girls
watching this at the moment about just
what it means to get up there and show
everyone what you can do doesn't matter
what age you are whether you're a boy or
girl kind of what's your driving
motivation around that
i mean
where i live in miyazaki or i feel or
honestly everywhere in the world i feel
like some people just
don't think they can do it and i had
some friends that are like nah
you know i'm a girl i really shouldn't
be doing this but
honestly if you
just get out there you know you can't
let all the boys have all the fun you
gotta go and
enjoy the time and i mean
enjoy life and try new things skype many
congratulations on that bronze medal and
we'll hope to see you in paris in three
years time